Louisiana bio informatics training a
summer training program in
bioinformatics in collaboration with the
Louisiana biomedical research Network
and the LSU Center for computation and
Technology course is being organized by
Pine biotech and is going to be
delivered in an innovative approach that
was designed to allow hybrid access both
online and offline project-based
education and computational analytics
for biomedical data and bioinformatics
onyx logic the purpose of this course is
to give a logic behind creating analysis
pipelines and applying different methods
to next-generation sequencing data high
throughput data that represents
biological phenomenon that is being
studied and this course is being done
with the help of the tower by
informatics Research Center which is a
research center focused on the
development the design and the
development of the T baiioons a platform
at University of Haifa in Israel and
Pine biotech a company based here in New
Orleans in Louisiana so we're pursuing
three objectives in this course
project-based learning we're going to
minimize the amount of theoretical
knowledge that we're going to cover and
focus on practical aspects on how to
apply various analyses to different
types of projects datasets we're going
to be using research grade tools tools
that you will utilize you will continue
you're able to continue using them
afterwards and real research projects
and the datasets that you are using now
or real research datasets and finally we
are looking for an environment where a
joint problem solving can help us see
the problem from different perspectives
and interact so that we can jointly
solve problems that arise
in this course we'll be utilizing the TB
landfill platform a platform that was
designed to simplify the complexity of
various types of public domain open
source and proprietary methods and
provide so to say an open box something
that you can look into and use as well
as learn about how the platform works so
we're not necessarily focused on coding
and knowing how to code and setting up
the environment we are focused on
demonstrating how the tools work and
then looking at projects that we can
analyze and gain experience from in the
application of these tools we're
combining theoretical knowledge with
analysis logic so we give an
introduction this course is going to be
focused on oncology and so the topics
the different projects that we're going
to be utilizing are all oncology related
but of course they have a difference in
the number of samples the background of
the samples the data itself might be a
little bit different here and there so
we're gonna take these different
variations of datasets and then we're
going to start by looking at suggested
pipelines pipelines that assemble
together a number of algorithms and that
are done in a sequential way processing
the raw data converting it into a visual
that we can interact with and finally
preparing and applying machine learning
algorithms on these data sets throughout
the preparation process you will be
seeing pop ups educational pop ups with
text explanations and links and those
will be included in the knowledge
assessment quizzes and finally an
evaluation on how you're able to apply
these different methods to different
types of data the course overview first
of all we started with this kickoff
workshop and we are discussing here
- practically approached the different
resources that we are providing
including courses the platform and the
project and then we are going to spend a
couple of weeks on introduction to
bioinformatics and online course that I
will show in a second and
transcriptomics one another online
course introduction to bioinformatics
covers big data challenges in biology
and biomedicine hypothesis free analysis
and biomedical applications of
bioinformatics and then transcriptomics
one will deal with next-generation
sequencing how to take raw
next-generation sequencing reads and
align them as well as quantify the
accumulated reads as a gene expression
level and explore that data using PCA
principal component analysis so that we
can visualize that data after these
basic courses are completed we are going
to come here to the Center for
computation and technology and have a
two-day workshop now this two-day
workshop is going to give you some
practical skills we will go through a
number of pipelines and compare results
and look at some of the methods that we
used in a pipeline and the second part
is going to be dedicated to an overview
of projects what types of projects we're
going to be dealing with and thinking
about different approaches that could be
relevant and interesting to individuals
and groups of participants within this
program after that workshop which is
going to happen on June 25 and 26 we are
going to spend a little more time going
through transcriptomics - and
transcriptomics 3 both of these courses
deal with quantification in a comparison
so the first option is differential gene
expression where you have a couple of
groups and you compare the different the
difference between gene expression
within samples own in those groups but
of course there are limitations to that
type of an approach for example
sometimes you have
a lot of variance within the group or
you might have more than two groups and
there's a challenge that could be
overcome with methods that now could be
described as machine learning methods or
data mining learning data mining methods
starting from unsupervised methods like
PCM clustering and in all the way to
building a supervised model for
classification like linear
discriminatory analysis support vector
machines and decision trees after that
we will have another hands-on workshop
and by that time we are hoping that
everybody has some level of project idea
that they can communicate and discuss in
a group setting and we will make sure
that everybody is on the right track I
spend some time reviewing some of the
additional methods that we didn't have
time to cover in the two-day workshop
and start the independent project and
the independent project we will cover
that a little bit today is an optional
thing you can either go with the project
that was discussed in transcriptomics
one two and three which is the PDX
project or you can choose another one we
curated two of them and prepared them as
educational exercises and in a
structured way or you can take a
completely independent project a data
set that you bring that might take more
time so we should plan accordingly
finally we will do a project review
where we will get together and do
presentations of projects as well as
look at how the teams operated
evaluation and provide certificates to
all participants of the program now the
first big part of this program is using
the online courses that you can find on
edu T - bio info these courses are
structured but they have text keywords
images and videos and what you will find
is that as you go through there will be
a lot of references to different methods
and those will be explained in charts as
such as you see right here and also if
you have any questions along the way
there's a chat box and you can always
ask questions now the second big part is
going to be the platform itself where
you do analysis and to do that analysis
you will be provided with these projects
so these are data sets that come from
the public domain
they have associated publications with
them and in the publications authors
describe what they use to analyze the
data and how did they interpret their
findings now we will provide examples of
how to do some of those methods or some
alternative methods that are similar in
the way that they work or perform a
similar similar function
what are these projects the first one is
the whole transcriptome profiling of
cancer tumors in Mouse PDX models an
interesting project where we learn about
the role of the micro environment the
tumor microenvironment and learn how to
differentiate between the mouse and the
human genes and possibly correlate how
various mouse and human genes and their
expression levels are correlated with
different subtypes of cancers the second
project is modeling precision treatment
of breast cancer using multiple types of
cell lines and therapeutic agents an
interesting project that takes multiple
patient-derived cell lines and they are
treated with various small molecule
drugs and then the efficacy of those
drugs is measured using a measurement
called
IG 15 and then there is a question of
whether we can find specific molecular
identification characteristics that can
help us envision how these drugs might
work better or worse in a patient the
third project deals with the tumor
associated macrophages
these are immune cells that could be
recruited by the tumor to actually
instead of suppressing the tumor
assisting in its growth and so we're
going to be looking at the change and
differentiation of these Timbs
over time and look at how to deal with
time course data the fourth project is
not provided as a prepared project but
it will be available as a publication
and a data set
it's a pan-cancer data set that involves
analysis of twelve cancer types and how
to use different molecular data to
perform classification we will hold
these workshops and these are just
examples of workshops that are either
online or in person again it's important
to separate the things that you learn
independently online is at your pace
whenever you have time and you can spend
however much time is needed to complete
everything during the workshops we will
try to review some of those materials
and address specific practical
considerations around when how and why
to use different methods of course at
the end of all of the program you will
receive the certificate of completion
and this will be from the Louisiana
biomedical research network throughout
the course we will ask you to fill out
several forms that serve as pre and post
assessments we do ask that you identify
yourself we plan to use this data in a
publication later on but we also want to
provide feedback to each one of you
individually as well as to the group and
the organizers of this course and we
would like to learn from this experience
and improve our courses as well as
provide you feedback about the skills
and concepts that you've learned
throughout this course at the very end
you will be able to see the projects
that individuals came up with we will
try and separate all of the this cohort
into a number of
groups and each one will be able to
propose a project and then collaborate
on that project together with other
members of that group and this is an
example of what we did at university of
Loyola in New Orleans Loyola University
in New Orleans and some of our online
students and what they thought about
this project-based approach
now the next workshop that we are
planning to do this workshop will happen
on June 25 and 26 again here at the
computation of the Center for computer
computation and technology the CCT at
LSU in Baton Rouge and there we will
start with an overview of some of the
critical review of the approaches how to
compare different approaches when to use
different sections like pre-processing
and different mapping isoform
construction and and expression level
quantification methods we will talk
about differential gene expression how
to compare fold change between so how to
quantify change and see whether change
is statistically significant between two
groups and then how to use machine
learning methods to classify different
samples and finally at the end when you
start learning about the projects and we
will start working on preparing ideas
for analysis of the data and these are
just some examples of students getting
feedback from faculty on their project
ideas and some of the methods that they
used in their analysis so this is
something that we plan to organize at
the end so that everybody has an
opportunity to both present and provide
feedback to their peers and faculty of
course are welcome to participate in
that as well that's it for now this is a
short overview
what we will cover in the summer program
in addition to this video we just posted
another video on the different sites the
edu site and the server site how to use
both of those how to utilize the
interface what is the difference between
the two when you go to one link and the
other and finally if you have any
questions you can definitely reach out
to us so everybody who is involved in
organizing this course is listed right
here and of course it's the LVN folks as
well as the LSU Center for computation
and technology and Pine biotech so reach
out to any of us with any questions or
suggestions recommendations if something
is not working please do let us know and
again thank you for joining the